welcome to the show today guys i want to
let you know that i have some tour dates
if you want to see me in live in the
live space visual
real time they call it irl
jacksonville florida february 2nd i'll
be there saint petersburg florida
february 3rd
orlando florida february 5th
lafayette indiana february 24th rockford
illinois february 25th chicago illinois
february 26th
tulsa oklahoma oh that's sold out now
may 6th we may add one there and then
los angeles california at the wilton may
7th
that is all return of the rat tour you
can grab those tickets or until now
theovonne.com
tour today's guest is a comedian and a
licensed breath work
teacher um i've been taking classes with
her and i'm really excited that she's
here uh miss blair
sake
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wow it's not intuitive don't worry
what do you mean intuitive like you
would think it's sochi
yeah i mean oh so i shouldn't feel bad
if since i didn't get it right
yeah
yeah i guess i'll always in my head have
been calling you blair sochi yeah
whatever you want yeah um yeah it's good
i think i could see you being either one
yeah some of my best friends don't even
know how it's pronounced i don't really
care yeah
um
so i know you we i know you've through
breathwork you you you
i know you do stand up comedy right and
but then
a friend of mine turned me on to you
recently about uh about doing breath
work yeah and i didn't know anything
about it and so i was like well what is
it you know
so
what is it
okay uh well yeah i started breath work
sort of at the beginning of the pandemic
uh
i just love i love learning i'm like
really curious person and i took a few
classes and sort of my mind was blown
uh
and then later on i i took a course a
certification course just because i
wanted to learn more about it i never
ever thought i would teach it or use it
or anything
um but basically it's like holotropic
breathing
and um
holotropic yeah and it's like this you
move your mic down just a little bit so
it's not in front of your face yeah okay
is that better can you see or is that
okay okay uh
and it's like a two-part it's a two-part
technique as you know through the mouth
and
uh you breathe deeply into the belly and
then a chest breath on top and then um
you know a easy exhale okay so i go so
it's inhale through the mouth yeah all
through the mouth nothing through the
nose okay
so stomach and then chest
and then exhale yeah yeah and then you
just try to keep a rhythm through the
whole thing and it just um
you know it alkalizes your
blood in a different way uh
than you're used to and all sorts of
crazy [ __ ] happens so do you know what
happens because the first time that we
did it you and i did it yesterday we've
done three sessions yeah
and um and thank you for that it's been
really interesting yeah dawg uh the
yesterday yeah my hands everything gets
real hard right like i can't even like
move my hands it almost feels like um um
like if you see a dead body or something
yeah they call it lobster claws it's
tetany and it's just because you know
there's a different amount of co2 in
your blood than usual it's called tetany
yeah you pull that up from your usual uh
breathing okay yeah so it's a big
difference in how much co2 is in your
body than your regular state of
breathing and so your hands go like that
but it's not nothing is wrong with that
there's nothing
that's going to happen and is it
poisonous because we used to sleep at my
buddy jeff's house and they had a
co2 leak i guess in his house or
something and we would sleep for like
literally 36 hours everywhere
that's really i'm glad you're still
alive yeah um yeah yeah definitely he's
alive also
that's really good but is that that's is
that co2 the car is that
no that's i mean that's an external co2
gas this is just
produced within your body so you're safe
but you know like if it is it is
sometimes a sign that you're going too
hard like you're being too forceful
especially on the exhale like
if you get too much of the technique
yeah yeah okay so let's bring it up i
just want to be able to see what it is
just so um
there you go
if you have experienced cosmic breath
work you may have experienced tetany
tetany is characterized by cramping
tightening tingling
paralyzing or numbing sensations of the
hands and or feet and even the face
oh wow so yeah i do remember now my face
got and my neck started to feel a little
bit like hard and tight yeah if this
does occur during cosmic breath work
note that it is very common and should
not be feared but what's happening
what's causing it it's just like a
dramatic increase of co2 okay into your
butt but i don't mind it like when i'm
doing breath work i just know i kind of
like it because i know it's working it's
sort of like when you're at the gym yeah
and you know you feel like botox like a
little yeah i mean
what i just what i love about it is i
just didn't even know that your body
could feel these ways or that you could
get to this stage just from breathing
right like i feel high after like i
don't know
uh well i don't know how many drugs
you've done but like it feels high like
it's really good yeah i've done it i've
done it almost i haven't done cry i've
never
i have never done crack i always
honestly always wanted to smoke crack
but um i've never wanted to but who
knows but i've never smoked crack before
but um
some of my buddy said but i've never
gotten into it you know uh but uh
but anyway yes so so yeah cause i i
didn't realize that so you're about yeah
i did feel after yesterday i felt really
high
i just felt really like
i don't know what i felt like i
definitely felt altered like in an
altered state yeah and the first time i
did it i mean i just
like it
i don't know what happened that was
different the first time but
it literally like i was at the end like
balling like just like
there was such a release of like um
i don't know what is that what happens
well colin and i were talking about it
before and he was saying he cries every
time and it's like you can go into a
session feeling great and then it'll
unlock something just like the energy
whatever you know hurt or
uh pain is in your body that you're not
even aware of your conscious mind
um so i cry a lot of times when i do it
and it's just like every time i'm so
surprised
um
it's crazy yeah i heard the first time i
did it i yeah i was like and then i had
to go to breakfast after with somebody
and so i was like and i kept moving the
breakfast back like 15 minutes i'm
literally sitting in my hotel room like
and i just like i just couldn't help but
just had all these feelings and
everything was so like raw it just felt
like it's like raw meat totally you know
yeah and then i had to go on jocko
willink who's like a navy seal guy to do
his podcast that day
and i walk in there like the complete
opposite of a navy seal i was like
i was oh
it was very it was a tough day to be in
front of like the toughest guys i think
i told you that they'll like expect to
be really raw after i mean sometimes the
sessions aren't that deep like i'll have
one and i'll i'll be like really wanting
to have some
like
excavating experience and it's just not
that but then sometimes it really
[ __ ] hits you yeah it blew my mind i
didn't know that something like that
could happen i didn't know
it just shocked me i didn't know that
that that much of you could have that
much of a release yeah i didn't know it
either i was stunned what uh what led
you to even want to learn about it
uh well
one i'm just a really curious person i
love trying new things especially uh
you know with my body or
spirituality or
you know
healing or wellness um as i get older i
take a lot better care of myself
especially with comedy and traveling so
much and
everything um but yeah i started reading
a book it's a famous one called the body
keeps score and it's basically the
premise is about how trauma is stored in
our bodies and
so
when i kept getting recommended breath
work because you bypass your conscious
mind like i've been in talk therapy
forever yeah so it's it's not good a lot
of times well it's just like you a lot
of times you're not getting like you can
talk about things without feeling
anything
oh interesting yeah and the feeling part
is what
makes you able to pass through something
i agree i need to have the feelings
about things so it's like when someone's
giving me information that never helps
me it's like my therapist i work best
with therapists that are able to like
trick me into having a moment where i
have a feeling and then it's like
yeah and then you can move through it
right yeah
we don't even realize how much we avoid
feeling feelings
and so like i think that's another part
of breath work it's like we're always on
our [ __ ] phones we're always doing
[ __ ] like first thing now yeah or
feelings are like sasquatches now yeah
it's crazy it's like well i think i had
a feeling what do you see any pictures
of it right and it's just in the
distance like that
i think also there's like an element of
panic around it because we do so little
of it right a lot of times yeah it's
crazy how quickly we're getting away
from like the things that are very human
yeah and then how almost alarmed we are
when they come up yeah
um
and then how we create so many medicines
and everything to like keep them at bay
right like whether it's like
uh antidepressants or even like ever all
the women are on like uh the that little
birth control nugget or whatever
nowadays you know so it's like
everybody you know it's like uh yeah so
it's anything that has like it's a
natural thing we have like oh we gotta
i'm really aware of it now like that
i've gotten into mindfulness and i
meditate a lot i'm really into
meditation and um i will be like oh i'm
reaching for my phone sometimes and it's
not because i actually intentionally
want to go on my phone it's just habit
and avoidance and like not wanting to
sit and be present or silent or bored
you know
yeah it's gotten so addictive um i
noticed it too i just started really
getting into meditation pretty good i
think about the past three weeks i've
been doing really well with it oh that's
great and i noticed like a little moment
there's like it's like a
millisecond between me doing something
and me
really realizing that i'm doing
something it's just like there's a
little bit of realization in there right
like oh like why are you like what are
you doing right now right and it's just
god it's almost such a relief because
for so long i've just been
doing and almost don't even like just
reactive everything feels so reactive
yeah it's it's so much doing instead of
just being yeah which sounds [ __ ]
trite but it's true
yeah um so where do you start comedy you
started in i started in new york oh you
did yeah you new york city person yeah
okay well i'm from orange county
california oh damn we are pretty rich
um
i hope to be more rich were you folks
pretty well off um they did well yeah
yeah what kind of jobs did they have um
my dad is in real estate oh nice yeah
and my mom uh
took care of us yeah yeah were they oh
she got to be a stay-at-home mom yeah oh
that's cool
yeah that's pretty cool were they like
an orange like was it like as soon as
you think about those oh the orange
county couple you know or like the
people get fancy down there kind of you
know it's just like some of the areas
you know yeah newport and stuff it gets
kind of fancy um my parents like my
parents didn't grow up with money
they're
they work really hard they're really
hard workers uh but yeah it could be
like that it's a strange place i didn't
quite understand until i moved away what
it really i mean i just grew up surfing
and playing volleyball that was like
really my
life yeah yeah um and so at what point
did you kind of think about comedy or
like
what kind of led you to maybe
did you know when you were younger that
you had that ability like what where
does it come from for you yeah well i'm
the youngest and only girl i have older
brothers and they had like a million
friends and i my family is like hyper
masculine like just the way i grew up
was like hunting fishing like sports and
so that was like sort of my currency to
just be a really good athlete and funny
to have any value in the family right
yeah yeah sometimes you create funny
because it's like oh i need to have some
sort of value yeah to even be allowed to
share air with my older brothers wow
yeah and you know they were so [ __ ]
cool and surfing and skating and like
uh great athletes and yeah and they tall
too yeah
my parents are like
these adonis people too they're like
very hot incredible shape
yeah it was like a nightmare to even be
like a little ugly at any point in my
life
yeah they have [ __ ] abs now oh my god
now 60s wow yeah i mean it's that level
that's wild yeah and did y'all live in
like newport or something around there
no we didn't live in newport we lived in
um san juan capistrano area oh yeah
that's pretty sometimes the train goes
by there yeah yeah and it looks really
nice or by saying clementi
yeah yeah sometime i see the train when
it goes by there it's like i always want
to get off right there just seem like a
nice little like kind of romantic spot
or something it is it's beautiful
um
so then see you you go to school down
there you and then when did you start
doing stand-up
uh
so
i started
in my mid well i went to uh new york for
grad school to be a novelist oh really i
didn't ever know that i was gonna start
comedy there was no intention i had i
didn't see my first comedy show till i
was 25. uh i had never been exposed to
comedy orange county is not like
a
cultural hotbed in any way it just like
wasn't in my sphere
um and i started dating a dude
right before i left for new york white
guy
yes
why
oh why don't we try to get some idea who
the guy is you know i just don't wanna i
bet you're briefly you're probably uh
aware of who he is but um oh okay so be
a comedian guy yeah oh she started
dating a comedian and he got but he
wasn't really a comedian yet he had just
like started open mics but he basically
like introduced me to comedy and then i
moved to new york we broke up and um i
was interviewing comedians because i was
a writer
and just like one day like six months
later i was interviewing michael che i
was his first inner piece of press ever
and like i was asking these questions
that in hindsight or someone who wanted
to start but my brain hadn't told me
that i didn't realize that yeah and then
like a couple days later in the shower i
had the thought and then i just started
and you just started where did you take
a class did you go to a um
i took a class which they don't teach
you anything it's basically the only
benefit is that no one else in there has
done it and so you're not afraid of
looking [ __ ] dumb and you're doing it
you're going to a place i took a class
so you're going to a place each week and
doing it yeah so there's a lot of value
in that and at the graduation the class
did you was it one where you guys got up
on stage at the end yeah yeah yeah it
was at gotham
and it just sort of was like an
immediate thing and i was like oh this
is it
i still finished my master's degree
because i didn't know it was gonna end
up being my career
just like lit money on fire but um and
you were living in new york city yeah
wow yeah and were you partying pretty
hard what's the part i mean it must have
been pretty sick right yeah it was it
was really cool and just like at that
point you know in new york it's such a
good place to start everyone says it's
not because you want to start in like a
small market but there was so much stage
time like all my friends we would just
be like drinking going a bunch of mics
it was really [ __ ] fun
and did you feel like it was male
dominated did you feel like it was like
what do you think about that kind of
stuff when people because there's a lot
of some women i think use that as like a
or some people use like their whatever
their thing that's different about them
as like a
we we're not there's not enough of us
represented does it feel like a male
dominated business to you
i mean it is a male dominated business
but that just never really crossed my
mind because i felt right at home given
the way i grew up and i never felt
interested you grew up in a male
dominant oh my god yeah i was like i'm
thriving right now like i never i was
not intimidated by any i was like oh
like i'm gonna be
afraid of this [ __ ] dork right i was
like
they were a virgin until they were 22. i
don't [ __ ] care you know
but i love them yeah i loved it i loved
the whole thing and like i loved being
around so many different types of people
that i was
not around growing up yeah yeah oh yeah
but yeah you know in new york you get in
any of the big cities you get like all
types yeah yeah because i really started
out here kind of in los angeles so oh
you did yeah so i think i can relate to
that like just there's so many different
types of people come passing through and
like you see so many people that start
out they start and then they get into
something else or it's like right you
see so many people's little career paths
kind of deter here and there you know my
hair is falling out
i swear i saw some of it the other day i
saw a damn
a bunch of it on the sink and it formed
a little eyebrow and took off
left for somewhere who knows probably
persia
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time they
are 35 dear god
dear god this is happening
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
and keeps
offers both of them
keeps
it's stress-free way to keep your hair
it's a pill low-cost treatment start at
just
10 bucks a month
keeps
offers generic versions as well
you don't want that top shelf stuff you
want that low that you know that
mid-grade hair keeper
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast if you're ready to take action and
prevent
hair loss real hair loss
go to keps dot com slash theo to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's k e e s dot com
slash t-h-e-o to get your first month
free keeps.com
theo you might want to save money people
want to save money you see people a lot
of times
have money under their house
you know you'll see somebody a burglar
go under there sometime you'll see a
burglar under your house
and he's looking for your money well
you can save money by switching to mint
mobile
it's the easiest way to save this year
it's the easiest you can't
name it name seven easier ways to save
money you can't
mint mobile lets you maximize your
savings with plans starting at just
fifteen dollars a month by going online
only and eliminating the traditional
cost of retail you see mint mobile
doesn't have a
brook and mortar store you can't find it
you drive around your whole life looking
for it they don't have it
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
no brook and mortar store the savings
goes to you
with mint mobile you choose the amount
of monthly data that's right for you
stop paying for data that you never use
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
theo that's m-i-n-t m-o-b-i-l-e.com
t-h-e-o
was there a time where you kind of knew
that it was we really felt like okay
this is this is kind of fitting in my
life or was there a time like in the
beginning where you were like this is
not uh
this is not really working for me
no i just sort of
clicked right away and then like i
uh
got cast on an mtv show like
almost less than two years in and um was
it the one that just made paluso did
that show no it was a spin-off of girl
code it was only a girl code banner but
it was a prank show nice yeah and that
sort of just started things and um yeah
and so that's and so then you've just
been doing it since then yeah do you
feel like i know we talk you mentioned
like or i mentioned i think about it's
male dominant does it feel like a why do
you think comedy is male dominated or
does it feel male dominated
well i think the act of comedy itself is
extremely masculine thing you're walking
on stage and and you're like yeah what i
have to say
is important and you guys will respond
to it like the whole thing is extremely
masculine in itself
um
yeah it's almost like a combat you're
almost going to a war in a way yeah it
feels like yeah um
in combat was stereotypically has always
been a male thing right kind of you know
yeah it's changing yeah you know but i
think like if you look at like kind of
like the
archetypes or whatever then it's usually
a man out there you know yeah and i
think also
uh the the population in the country
really i mean it's also changing in this
way because of podcasting and um online
specials and social media and all this
stuff but like before i started a comedy
i was maybe aware of five comedians yeah
and they're only the top five big like
you're not really aware of the um comedy
landscape right and so i don't think
people really have been exposed to that
um many female comedians and i don't
like to think about it because i don't
want to
have that perspective i don't think it's
helpful for me yeah to be like no no
one's gonna you know whatever i have a
[ __ ] but um i do notice it sometimes
like online
where you'll see like youtube comments
or something and you're like oh the rest
of the country only thinks
men are funny just naturally it's just
like a misogynist thing yeah and but
also who gives a [ __ ] about them you
have your own audience whatever yeah i
think i mean well finding your own
audience is key i mean i think different
places i i think
and i don't even know if it's the rest
of the country thing i don't know it's
like
it always seems like i here's what i
think sometimes as when i think about
male and female comedians
i always men it always seems like
they are
and maybe this is just because i've seen
this in television and film over the
years but they're like the goofball
they're the
the [ __ ] you know they're the bat
bumbling um you know yeah i know what
you mean and so you don't mind if
something happens to the bumbling
you don't mind if that guy steps in a
fire slips on a banana peel
for me the thing that always
and this was the same thing about you
watching ufc women i didn't like it at
first i didn't like it because it felt
like i didn't think oh these people
shouldn't be able to do this right i
think anybody should do whatever they
want it just was like i always thought
of women as like mom yeah exactly and
like a sister right so when you think
about oh man my sister you know it it's
a male instead of yours it's your
sister's getting in a fight that you
help or like
and then comedy i always felt like was
such an uncomfort
i think also so it was like man this is
so uncomfortable you don't a woman
doesn't need to go through this
that's what my dad said like i should
put my if i see a woman walking on stage
i should put my coat down over like you
know yeah so that she has a gentleman
step in the state you know or step in
the the so i think there's a lot of that
i don't know if it's that
for me it was never that women
shouldn't do this
but i did always i think and it wasn't a
choice i made no it's an unconscious
bias like for you you're saying it's
like a certain fragility that you're
worried
about
yeah i just felt like why do we like
why do women have to do why do they need
to uh endure this
that's literally what my dad said to me
like when i first started he's like
you're one of the smartest people i've
ever met why are you choosing to put
your life in a basement with drunks and
fuck-ups
and i was like fair fair point you know
but also it's just like it is what it is
it's like uh like my i think what you're
saying is totally real like because i
feel that way that i'm received that way
in orange county because they cannot
fathom that a woman would not my own
focus and priority would not be to be
married with three kids right now right
and like my family's never seen me my
brothers have but my my parents have
never seen me do comedy before
wow or any of my tv stuff either well
here's something also that happens a lot
of women start doing comedy right and
i'm probably going to receive hell for
this because it's a very it's a
generalization here's something that i
sometimes feel
could be realistic and i don't know here
we go um
and they and then the first thing they
do is beat this woman drum
instead of beating the comedy drum you
know it's like
um
you mean off stage
yeah kind of it's like i'm a female like
somebody'll been doing it a month and
they're big and they're just like i you
just start getting into like
this i'm a and i think maybe it was a
kind of a fad that happened for a while
it was like um
and maybe women needed to maybe they
need to do that to make sure that
they're seen in like a in like a
male-dominated environment you know but
i feel like sometimes uh
people will lean so much on any whatever
it is that makes them
like oh i'm southern or i'm a woman or i
was on fire you know you see some guy
and he's got skin grafts he's like i was
on fire you know that's his big thing
and he's like you know
fire shows you know we're doing
everybody who's on been on fire ever you
got to be on you know you're on the fire
lineup only yeah you know
victim you know like somebody neck brace
line you know it's neck brace night at
the [ __ ]
um
and i don't think it's a bad i'm not
saying it's a bad thing i don't know
what i'm saying exactly
i guess i'm saying some people attach
themselves so much to something
that they
forget that what they're doing is that
you we still have to do the thing yeah i
mean i feel two ways i'm not saying that
about you no i don't think you've never
even seen me do comedy yeah
i wonder if that's true or not
i don't think so
uh
but yeah i
i want to be aware of [ __ ] and sometimes
i can feel things
like a lot of times
when i'm in a green room i mean less now
that i'm like more known but
like immediately when you walk in a
green room if it's like a older comic or
a famous com they think that you're the
girlfriend of another dude
and it's just like but like that's not
something i'm gonna get upset about but
i can feel it immediately when i walk in
or um
when i'm on stage like you know comedy
though is a meritocracy like it's an
instantaneous reaction if you're not
good it's very apparent yeah
and like yeah i think so but then the
industry also started to adjust where
they're just picking people because of
things
and that i think has certainly loosened
up i think some of the meritocracy of it
yeah that is a
true
like it's much more diverse in in tv and
everything and movies and opportunities
and stuff um and i think that's a good
thing i don't think people should
you know necessarily get something
uh
for
without
handing value but i like the diverse
perspective
but
yeah i don't know yeah i think it's good
because i do think it's good in the
sense that it helps like um
it does help diversify things some you
know it's like it helps like
uh plant seeds and people who maybe they
also need inspiration they're young in
their career or it's like maybe a face
you wouldn't normally get to see because
things are so
if things are so often the same way you
know
it gives different people opportunities
i think it's less
less uh
stand-up is less driven by that than you
know say television right just hollywood
in general yeah like you see i don't see
these lineups or whatever and i'm like
yeah that wasn't the um designing factor
yeah
um yeah it's interesting it's
interesting because i wonder yeah why do
i sometimes feel like or what are some
of the things that make me feel like
it's a man sport or that it makes i
think yeah i think those are the things
for me about that it's like there's some
fragility to it that you don't want it's
like a
i mean i don't know you well but you
seem
like the
area of comedy that you roll in is hyper
masculine and the people that you're
friends with
yeah
i guess so yeah i mean i have some
female comedian friends you know um
[Music]
but i guess yeah i mean i guess more of
my comedian friends are probably man
probably
yeah i mean that makes sense yeah are
more years women you think
uh no i have like a mix i mean
i always say like i don't really like
being a woman
the the best part about being a woman is
female friendship like my
girlfriends in comedy are it's just like
the best thing in the world because
we're not really like it's such a uh
it's such a
distinct uh way of life that many people
don't understand and especially like
growing older as a woman uh people can't
really understand like why you would
want to do it so it's like you really
understand each other in a way that
other people don't right but um no i
love all my guy friends and yeah
yeah it's interesting it's so there's
also so few people that do it yeah um
[Music]
there's when you think about it like
even when you said like there's you know
you know like five minutes until you get
into comedy and then you realize so many
people have know nothing about comedy
totally you're like in the world so you
know you start to like but then there's
some people have no idea about like they
couldn't like chris right they would
just name chris rock like yeah eddie
murphy you know
yeah they wouldn't know robin right yeah
you know um they have one point of
reference like uh a lot of my
girlfriends uh and i joke about it but
like so many people will be like and
they'll be trying to compliment you but
it's [ __ ] rude they'll be like you're
like a more funny amy schumer or like a
less funny amy schumer whatever it is
they're just comparing you and it's like
you could just say good job right
[ __ ] yeah people don't know how i mean
i think some people also they just don't
know that much you know like you're
saying if they're trying to give you a
com some people are bad at compliments
yeah it's always like backhanded or
whatever but it's the point is that they
have one woman and she has blonde hair
right and so they immediately they're
like i have to make that association and
i have to tell it directly to this
person yeah yeah yeah i wonder what is
it what is that in people that makes
them that makes us feel like we have to
do that sometimes
um
i think it's just because you want to
try to feel connected you want to try to
share something you know it's
interesting because if an old person
says it you'll give them less grief than
you would if like a young person says it
yeah um
that's how i tried to think about like
online comments you know like if you see
a crazy person yelling in the street
where they're like you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what i mean and i'm like
i didn't take that in well i was just
like that person's out of their [ __ ]
mind right but if you see it online
but that's why i treat them like oh
they're not well they're commenting on a
person they don't know they've never met
who would do that take the time in their
day to do that yeah yeah
who do i see the other night oh jessica
michelle singleton is so funny have you
seen her perform before yeah i liked us
good jesus christ dude it was one of the
best sets i've seen in so long oh that's
so nice she's so sweet too she's such a
good person it was f ah it was so funny
man that's great yeah it made me feel
like damn
it was just really really impressive um
yeah i wonder why else i've ever thought
like that maybe because also when i was
growing up they didn't have like i guess
you had i'm trying to think of female
comics that i saw growing up
joan rivers yup joan rivers paula
poundstone yeah i remember um
roseanne who i loved who was like
probably one of my favorites
uh
they've always had a good deal of female
comedians though
i guess like they didn't used to have
that many comedians that people knew
about yeah sarah silverman
yeah yeah
i think hollywood's always done a decent
job of putting up
probably a like pretty diverse group
except when it gets outside of black
white and female
after those i feel like it kind of fell
off
now it's different
i think now things have been changing
and going in a great direction but like
the women before me
they always said like you know they
could be better than some dudes in clubs
like around the country wouldn't
headline them because they said like
people wouldn't come
you know so it's like based on like but
then who's that is that anybody's fault
though or is that just business like you
can't it's business but it's [ __ ]
dumb because it's not based on
necessarily on talent like when you see
like laurie kilmartin when you watch
laurica martin she's like one of the
best joke writers in the country and she
just
murders and to think of like a mediocre
dude headlining over her is sad right
you know what i mean right but i think a
lot of that goes to like
just business it's the same as like like
you could put a ton you could lay you
could put a a a line up and diversify it
all you want right but in the end if it
doesn't sell t if people aren't buying
tickets to go see it like if the if the
people aren't buying tickets to go see
it then no the market is dumb
right
so yeah yeah in the end it's like yeah
it just has to be so meritocracy it
doesn't always figure out i guess then
does it no meritoxy is what i mean is
just on stage where you're like right
okay we'll see who's good and who's not
oh i've seen tons of people over the
years that get opportunities because of
like nepotism
religion
um
you know like uh certain friendships
that kind of stuff just happens i think
it happens in all walks of life you know
yeah
like you see but that's also the thing
that makes you keep [ __ ] going like
if if you showed up and just walked in
or like hey i'm here
and i'm funny and just because i'm
black female was in a fire you know
died and came back to life i love how
you keep saying
was in a fire as if that was someone's
thing won't this thing in different oh
it certainly is man they got all these
shows it's like i saw one one show it
was like uh
i haven't been going to these shows
you've been going to it's just some of
the things i get you know i get a link
or something hey check out this and it's
all like
um like not of not victims affliction
well like affliction night i said
publicly do not ask me to do your all
female show that it's like ladies of
laughter or some [ __ ] i'm like that is
so [ __ ] humiliating why don't you
just call it look at these clams yapping
like i cannot i mean like i cannot even
fathom that [ __ ] it's so embarrassing
well here here's so that here's
something that happens i think
a lot of men also for me i remember like
i was so it was so tough sometimes like
um
who was that talking about one time
oh nikki glaze when i first heard her
act it reminded me for some reason of my
mother specifically and so i like
couldn't listen or accommodate the
beginning because there was just some
weird correlation between like her and
what my mom sounded like to me growing
up right yeah it's not that way now i
mean and she know i've taught it's just
been like a funny thing but
um
and i'm sure maybe girls women in weird
ways
right and girls probably do the same to
guys i bet yeah well and there's also
just a thing of like
you know
it's good to be able to do well in front
of everyone but there are demographics
that are going to be not more naturally
drawn to you and your material and who
you are and what you're talking about
like i don't like right which is totally
fine and that's
like the other night i did a show at
that comedy jam jam in the vans
so
and then we had a uh there was a
comedian on the lineup who's a female
comedian right she says to me then the
crowd was pretty diverse
she comes up to me after the show she
goes hey i just want to say i saw your
crowd very diverse group you're really
doing your job that's what she said to
me
and i'm like i will never work with this
girl again for saying that because like
you know how hard it is to get any
audience you think i'm i have to get a
certain type of audience like that's
[ __ ]
crazy to me like
i'm happy to sell any tickets like
now i have to make sure each audience
member like this person you know has a
hat this person has glasses this
person's a ginger this person's a
filipino like that's [ __ ] impossible
yeah right like
i don't know and maybe i had like i mean
i could have had like an overreaction it
just seemed like
and this was a girl who doesn't sell
tickets which is fine right
but it was like are you really telling
me like that i have to have now a die
like a diverse audience like
it just [ __ ] was like that's
impossible
okay maybe some people it's possible but
i love that you had it and this is a
person who doesn't sell tickets yeah
well it's like coming from her it's like
yeah you would think that hypothetically
in this perfect world it would be great
if every time you walked out there there
was like a perfect rainbow of an
audience i mean i would love that
personally for me like you know there is
nothing better on earth as a white woman
than making black people laugh right
there's no better feeling in the world
but oh yeah but like yeah i mean you can
control it and people like i'm sure a
lot of you know southern people are
drawn to you i don't have a big southern
audience actually oh yeah
but um
yeah most of my tickets i sell australia
portland is my biggest audience oh yeah
because i don't have a country audience
i'm not a country guy oh um
but
yeah it's funny you would think that
though well i don't know what's country
just like you're from aren't you from
now i'm from louisiana yeah but yeah but
i don't sell it's like i do great there
you know but i don't it's not like my
biggest markets
yeah and it never has been really um
but yeah i don't know i just felt like
that was such an ins like
you're really doing your job like what
the [ __ ] are you talking
about what do you i don't know i don't
know why i'm bringing that up right now
i guess because we're like talking about
that kind of stuff yeah but it just
blows like what
like you can't control who comes out
there
yeah
you know and you work so hard to get
anybody to come out there
that you are grateful i'm grateful for
those people i don't care what [ __ ]
column care if they have no heads or
arms yeah if they have a heart that
cares and wants to be there yeah then
i'm grateful for that yeah you would
love a limbless
totally fine yeah you'd love them to be
wheeled into your show
yeah yeah yeah i mean it would be fine
um
but yeah i just thought that mindset
that like now i wonder if that's a
mindset that some comedians feel now
that like man now i have to get this
perfectly diverse audience you know i
don't know i don't think about that [ __ ]
i just try to be a good person i'm for
diversity but you know just do what i
can do and
there's so much you can't control
yeah
yeah i don't know i mean i don't really
know a lot of people that aren't for
diversity i guess um
that's good yeah i mean it's kind of
inevitable you know you can't even
really be racing anymore because
everybody's so mixed now you know it's
like [ __ ] almost impossible you
almost have like a real chart if you're
really gonna be racist like you gotta
really [ __ ] do some homework you know
yeah i feel like anyway
um
so what other stuff have you tried
outside of breath work uh
i really did a lot have you like so cool
like quarantine and i've always been
like this i was like this since i was a
little kid i was raised catholic
but like my parents when i would ask
them about god they just like change the
subject but it's like an italian thing
it's just like culturally catholic
because my dad's like full italian okay
um but
i was like
i would think deeply about all of it
like really seriously and i always was
like
reading and i just love learning and so
um
you know i've been in therapy for a long
time and uh
when quarantine hit i was like oh and
now i can't do stand up like i had this
time
and i just started taking like all these
weirdo online courses i did i took
breath work and like you took it online
through zoom yeah i was taking breath
work classes for the first time and i
just couldn't believe it it was amazing
um
because you know i was reading those
books that are saying like trauma stored
in your body in like your physical
body and your tissues and everything did
you believe that when you heard it at
first yeah i mean there's like a lot of
research about it
uh
and
you know if you had any abuse or
anything it's in there like beyond your
conscious
mind
um and then like i took reiki
certification wow yeah i just was like
and i just do all this stuff for fun oh
it's fascinating yeah like i like
learning about it and i take a little
from each thing i don't like
i don't treat anything as dogma yeah and
then i took tm meditation certification
yeah and then i did ayahuasca oh wow
yeah um
so i want to go through a little bit of
that so
uh
what
what do you say you said
um
breath work breath work and you got
certified to teach it yeah wow i took
two
uh levels of courses the first one is
just to teach one-on-one and then the
second level is to teach like group
classes and how long does that
certification stuff take um it's a
certain i don't know how it's like
how many hours would it have been
probably like 16 hours per level
you do like it was online dang yeah and
are you like practicing your neighbors
and [ __ ] like what are you how do you is
there well i wasn't gonna teach it it
was never i was never gonna teach it you
were just learning it to learn i was
just like interested yeah and you know i
wasn't on the road i wasn't doing
anything and it was just fun and um
and then like nine months after i took
it like some of my friends were like
people are all really [ __ ] up around
us like you should just do an online one
and i was like no that's weird
especially like
you know comedy and stuff like it would
be like a vulnerable thing to be like
take my refwork class yeah um but yeah i
like put made an online thing
and a bunch of people came and they
really liked it and then i've done like
two cents and i'm doing another one i
hadn't i haven't done one since june but
i'm doing one on tuesday um
yeah
um
do you haven't done one of your own you
mean
no i haven't had a virtual class or like
that people she'll do a virtual oh and
anybody can go yeah so is it the same
like the lesson that you gave me
yeah
personalized right yeah i can't
personalize it for like a big group but
right like when we do a session
um you know i think britney is the one
that told you you're yeah brittany uh
connor no
britney schmidt i'm sorry
bernie hunter went to my high school oh
sorry because brittany hunter i i she
was a great woman i don't know i i don't
know i think she's still alive i don't
know
but um i think she was my school i don't
even know actually i remember like one
person from high school so really yeah
wow
you just don't you we're not a fan you
just did you thrive in high school
i did
everything was going great
until something bad happened oh in high
school yeah oh
um
[Music]
but like
yeah
and i did thrive you did yeah were uh
how do you feel like you thrived like
were you funny then
i was funny like i was a surfer i was
like like star volleyball player i went
to ucla you went to ucla for volleyball
oh wow really yeah oh dang yeah
dude what a babe huh
uh
it was so high school was good but i
some [ __ ] did go down that really was
tough
was it um my coach
your you had a coach
yeah that
was
abusive yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry to hear
that oh it's okay thank you um is that
one of the things that you made you want
to do like seek out some of these other
things yeah and like you know i'd work
my whole life i was like junior national
team all this stuff like volleyball and
this is in college uh yeah and then like
it was just kind of
i
mentally wasn't
like
pro it just wasn't great for me because
everything that happened and stuff and i
quit like two years in
um so you had a you had a abusive
experience with a coach yeah and i
started on how to ask about no
you're doing great yeah i'm curious it's
process okay not like yeah okay so you
had so you were in high school when this
happened
yeah wow yeah and it was a a coach of
yours yeah and did was there charges was
it no like what can i ask you what
happened i mean it was like a sexual
abuse thing and um
like
there was
i've talked about it i'm trying to be
brave because i don't i get nervous
asking about certain things yeah yeah
yeah so for me i'm not trying to like i
don't want you to be uncomfortable no no
i'm i'll only go as far as i want to go
okay
and i don't want you to feel like i
expect you to talk about no no it's um
but i think it if it's i do think it's
interesting if
what our traumas are or why you know
because that breadth class the first one
i took from you [ __ ] blew my mind
like i'm on the phone with my brother i
can't even talk right because i'm crying
you know and he thinks just something's
wrong with a connection and i'm like
[ __ ] something's wrong with every
connection in my life yeah yeah yeah for
sure and like these things um
impact us
like subconsciously for a long time and
i was in therapy and
you know therapy is great and i got to a
place where i could you know talk about
it totally comfortably and
and was it a relationship that you had
with a coach uh yeah i mean there was
like i found out there was like many
other people besides me but um
unfortunately
uh but yeah really was just so
disorienting in like a really
developmental like sensitive time of my
life wow and especially like this thing
where i sort of felt like i had to
choose between
saying something or like
um
ruining my which sadly i still think was
the right choice
because i was like i'm not [ __ ] up my
dream of playing division volleyball at
my division one volleyball my dream
school
you know yeah um so i didn't say
anything say [ __ ] um
and then yeah just i sort of started
processing and when i was older
i ended up doing uh talking about it and
stand up like uh
like sort of before the pandemic and i
was never like one of those people that
was like i have to be confessional
comedy or whatever i was like i would
only talk about this if it was not for
any sort of like processing trauma but
because it was really [ __ ] funny
um and so i did that and that was really
cool but also really uh
it wore on me a lot more yeah
i could only i only did it
yeah because it was so different like i
i talked about it um i thought like i
talked about it so much that it's like i
feel great
talking about it on stage every night uh
took so much out of me physically and
also before i got it like good you know
but right oh but that [ __ ] was trauma
bombing
there's nothing sadder yeah no it's not
nothing more no i just got molested
again
and then i put that set out by silence
yeah
i was like you guys are injuring me
right now um
but yeah like i'm really proud of that
set like i think it's like one of the
funniest things i've ever done
um wow yeah what would you do if you
didn't have high interest loans or
credit card debt what would you do
if you didn't have a high interest rate
mortgage you didn't have credit card
debt what would you do
go to guam maybe
go to bahrain go to uh
go to ohio take a trip somewhere do
something
well if you dread looking at your credit
card statements then you're just like me
and just like millions of others
but upstart can help you on your path to
financial freedom
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online
yep
you can use you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
minutes for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand
dear god they've got so many amounts
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com slash theo
that's upstart.com
t-h-e-o don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you
we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application upstart.com
theo you know if you don't change things
up they get stale
they get um
they get real
uh
if you don't change things up they get
the same
and the same is not exciting after a
while
the same can be boring especially when
it comes to fitness
if you do one exercise forever you do
calf raises
and you don't do anything else
you'll probably die
but you'll have strong strong legs
bottom legs
peloton is stepping in to the
new
change
when it comes to fitness they're doing
new things new offerings
added to their lineup
they've got boxing now that's right
discover a fast furious fun workout with
peloton instructors in your corner
they've got new artists series of music
you listen to new music you like it you
listen to some adele you listen to some
damn accounting crows some uh
uh
young m.a listen to it all
whoever else you like
willy willy uh
willie nelson
from pop and rock to hip hop they've got
all types of new uh
stations you can listen to specifically
specifically on their platform more
daily workout variety a workout for
every goal day and mood you got 10
minutes they got 10 minutes you you got
a half hour they can help you you want
yoga you want to do abs uh
they can help
bike workout meditation dance cardio
it's all on there for a limited time
only try the peloton app
free for two months then 12.99 a month
after
new members only visit onepeleton.com
app to learn more that's two months free
at o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
offer expires 131-222 terms apply
so when all that so that you quit
volleyball at the time because it was
just all of it was too much no i
wouldn't say it was because of that like
i wouldn't it was just like
it was it had been so much
uh
that it was just i was overwhelmed wow
like because i wasn't mentally
and obviously i didn't have any support
and told anyone you know whatever it was
uh yeah it was really crazy experience
and how much of that when you look back
on it now um
and if it's a not a fair thing to ask or
something just let me know because i
don't really know sometimes but um
how much are you able to try and examine
the psyche of whatever that person that
like you know the abuser was like are
you able to like
try and
not obviously understand where they're
coming from but see like
you know because now you seem pretty in
tune with like
feelings and why people do stuff maybe
i'm sure you've had a lot of
you know a lot of going through a lot of
your own stuff with that are you able to
like
i don't know what i guess no am i able
to forgive this person
yeah like how do you find some footing
to be able to forgive somebody because
that would be [ __ ] hard um i don't
think yeah i mean i've really had a
whole process with that i don't think um
obviously it's not a well person it's
like they're mentally sick
you know a kid like when i see like a 16
year old now i'm like that's a baby
right uh and so you are not well if
you're
somebody trying to date a baby yeah if
you're a child
um yeah but i
i i just see it as a sick person and you
know i had to it's painful and all this
stuff but um yeah it's just like i have
to
move forward and enjoy my life like you
do have to look directly at these things
to get through them
uh but yeah i want to have a good life
i'll say
it's like i do have like commitment
issues that i'm working through at this
point in my life
yeah
wow i bet
it's just like i mean i could yeah you
don't realize the side effects of like i
think sometimes we don't even realize
the side effects of certain things like
all the little things that it can go
into you know yeah like all have these
like nice men try to get close to me and
i'm just like
i don't know but i'm working through it
yeah
um
that's crazy it reminds me like
it just makes me think when i was
growing up they had like coaches that
would get
in trouble for date yeah like there was
a lot of that i mean there's so much
[ __ ] that goes on now there's so
much pain in the world there really is
and it and it's like there really really
is and like i i want to be
each person that heals himself and gets
well it has a ripple effect and is able
to be more kind to the people around
them and to make the the world better
and less full of pain yeah and like i
want to be have children i don't want to
be really solid and
yeah right yeah it's hard it's hard to
do that i struggle a lot with that
commitment stuff and it's so [ __ ]
hard for me like my whole life it's
always been hard for me to like say like
this is my girlfriend like i ne there's
nothing makes me
cringe more
than saying like that
i'm attached to anybody is it because it
um limits your options
no i don't think that that's it i think
it's like some i mean i'm sure there's
been times where obviously maybe i did
what didn't want to be in a relationship
or something
but i think
for me when i was young like the only
thing i felt like i had was the way you
saw me like
i was always like hyper managing like my
um
like i'd hated where we lived i hated
our financial status i didn't like our
family we had no family set up all these
things that i had no control over
yeah
that [ __ ] mate just were like made me
so angry or uncomfortable and then
the only thing i could control was how
you saw me like when you saw me yeah how
you saw me so it was like i was
constantly trying to manage this image
of like i would take different buses to
different neighborhoods and then [ __ ]
walk them just weird [ __ ] but then i
always like was i think it was like well
if i have somebody else attached to me
and they do something weird or
uncomfortable or whatever then that's
gonna be a reflection of how you see me
it was just too much of a liability it
was it's because it's all an outward
focus
right like i'm concerned with what
people yeah i get that like i think
that's something that's so
natural especially as like teenagers and
that whole time period and and then as
you get older that's something i'm
really focusing on we talked about it in
breath work but like
i really want to not look outward
and that's i stopped i really have been
negotiating my relationship with
instagram too because i feel that's all
looking outward yeah i'll black out and
like lose an hour just like watching
[ __ ] instagram stories and i'm like
this is hell this is um this is not like
an intentional thing i don't want to
know what these people are [ __ ] doing
this is literally hell on earth i'm
afraid of being on my [ __ ] death bed
and being like i didn't live life i was
just looking at instagram stories yeah
you know what i mean
and so i'm i and like now also
i'm really trying to
think about like
especially it is hard when we do this
thing where you are really putting
yourself out there to be seen
and that can be diff it's hard to be
vulnerable in like a public
life like this and so in my mind one
thing i'm working on is just maintaining
my energy no matter who i'm around like
nobody is above me right nobody is below
me who whoever they are
yeah so that i'm not like outside myself
oh i see what you're saying so it keeps
everything in this ground where it's all
like it's going to be the same no matter
what so that's a lot more manageable i'm
not trying to impress anyone
and i'm not trying to look down on
anyone right that's like the state that
i'm trying to damn girl that's a real
tight rope yeah i mean it's good no it's
a great i love it
right now be around like really big
[ __ ] people and they're just a person
yeah and i'm also around people like
i don't want i want to be regular with
them i want to treat that person
that's like
but like not wherever i am the exact
[ __ ] same yeah
sometimes it's hard dude they had this
guy in like in a park next to our uh
my place out here and he was like
playing this drummer all night and he
was not a drummer right so that's a real
that was a lot you know
um explained himself yeah
kind of but kind of like not during
business hours you know so sometimes
it's hard man to just try to treat
everybody well and not [ __ ] throw
limes at that guy oh yeah i know i will
now i'll be like
aware of my impatience
because you might be a highly sensitive
person yeah which is 20 of the
population is it really i identify
unfortunately to my
humiliation as one of those people
i don't want to be a highly [ __ ]
sensitive you don't most of this
audience is probably
that's my audience actually it's like no
i mean highly sensitive
uh
to environment noise
you know oh yeah i am he
sent
like all sorts of things like i really
am that and it it doesn't i it's a
little it'll come up and i'm like i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this person but then
i'm like no no relax how can you
surrender how can you just allow this
reality to be since you have no control
of it anyways yeah that's true but
sometimes you gotta [ __ ] put the
hammer down it's impossible enough
sometimes not to put the [ __ ] hammer
down yeah you know um
yeah it's hectic it's an interesting
it's it's interesting these days i feel
like uh
serenity is definitely feels like more
of a commodity you know we're so in
everything is so inundated and when you
get like especially you get on social
media you get on your phone i really
feel like i fall into a
war hypnotized yes and because i will
literally come out of it and i'll tell
people i'll be like i'm back i'll say
that i find myself saying that like i've
just just gone somewhere i've i do i've
started deleting it off my phone during
the day oh wow because i just think it's
a nightmare well instagram's instagram's
whatever tick tock's the [ __ ] hard
one though i don't know how to take
yourself oh i'm not pulling anything is
good though but that's the problem
though they fine-tuned it and made it
honestly
well no they just made it pretty good
like tic toc i'm watching like a couple
of [ __ ] you know you can watch somebody
do knitting you can watch like just
quiet asians dude it's like total you're
just watching asian people be quiet like
you can there's so many things it's just
like you can watch somebody doing a cake
you can watch somebody oh just turning
the pages of a book yeah like it's
definitely like they [ __ ]
they went all out i just want less
all together like yeah i
want to just become a movie star already
so that i can move to [ __ ] montana
and fly in for my role
and then go
back out away from everyone yeah okay
yeah
yeah i like that maybe
how do you think you would like it out
there on like a ranch or something
yes i [ __ ] would you do yeah i don't
i just want to like i
maybe i'm getting old i just like love
the quiet like i need to keep up with
all this [ __ ] i don't care i don't want
to i don't need to see you cooking eggs
but will you not have the ability then
to draw from stuff i mean i know that's
kind of like uh
will you not have the ability to draw
from stuff no i have more because like i
hike almost every day like no i'm trying
to be in nature like a nature comic yeah
i'm in nature
no i just get like when my mind is still
like it was when i was a kid and i
didn't have phones or anything and i
would daydream or think up makeup worlds
and all this imagination and [ __ ]
like that's when [ __ ] comes to me like
jokes always come to me when i'm in the
shower i'm getting a massage i'm outside
away from a screen is when there's space
for things to come into my head yeah and
i get i can be like think of silly
things or think of we like weird
perspectives
do you um
a lot of rich people are going to outer
space you know it
yeah bird and do you think that uh
do you think that that's fair
um
i try not to think about what's fair and
not fair
i feel like that i mean
i do in some ways trust me i want things
to be like equitable for all people
i mean like
i don't know why that whole thing is
happening they could redirect that money
to things that
need it yeah but also i mean what do i i
have no control over it i don't [ __ ]
care but do you think because some
people think there's like rich people
are meeting up and spare like there's
like another place
that they're all
that's [ __ ] insane
i have not heard we're all at like
walmart and they're at like a
chick-fil-a in the sky you know well
yeah no i have not considered a
chick-fil-a
in the sky yet
uh cause it seems like that a little you
know it seems like they're all going up
there and yeah just look you know like
look at it um
i'm not i mean i probably am somewhat i
think i think certainly a lot more
levels of like people wondering what's
going on you know i think you start to
see like a lot of like
as we get further away from like any
type of faith and religion or any like a
lot of people do not have a real strong
sense of faith i don't think these days
so i think when you get like out there
like that then you start to people look
at conspiracies more they want they're
looking for something people are always
looking for something
to believe in i feel like a reason a per
you know like a
they want uh
an answer do you have faith
yeah
like in a judeo-christian god or what
yeah i mean i believe in god i believe
in a higher power and for me i use god
as that
is the sidewalk for that for me yeah so
i think different people use different
things you know yeah i mean i've tried
on many different things yeah yeah
um but now i just think of god as like
divine loving intelligence like
completely divorce of all religion
though religion
i don't know at this point doesn't
really seem
like it for me like when i think of the
catholic [ __ ] i'm just like that's
[ __ ] insane like how are these [ __ ]
not arrested ever yeah like what do you
mean like for what
like the catholic rape thing
i went to catholic school there was a
priest at every school i went to was
transfer oh yeah and then i saw like a i
saw a headline the other day that france
just france
has had like 350 000
abused kids imagine being romantically
molested
but i'm like that's [ __ ] insane how
that they're fully a religion is fully
protected globally where
well now it's basically legal sex abuse
yeah
that's crazy that's totally crazy well
it's also i mean it's like and then that
also that they don't pay taxes it's
crazy that none of these things are like
charged there's like
it's unbelievable and especially when
it's like people need they want some
reason they want some
you know a lot of people want church
they are also brought up in churches so
it's like a comfortable place you know
one of the things i love about church is
like you go and you see like kids are
playing together it's fun it's like a
fun place families get together yes it's
it's a family-oriented thing that's the
thing i love about it that's one thing
to me it's really nice there's a lot of
really good things like but it's crazy
why they cover these guys up why they
like why don't they send they would be
has so much more integrity if they
shipped all those [ __ ] to jail to
australia they said
they put them in jail they said we are
cleaning out our institution yeah but
they're not and then you would be like
oh bravo you know like
but hollywood could do the same thing
hollywood's just a [ __ ] crit it's a
[ __ ] great it's definitely a religion
yeah our co-workers are yeah
it's great i love saying hello to them
all the time hello at my place at work
it's really good
but do you have
hello
do you think it brings but then i think
that just goes back to just how much
like there's just a damaged element to
being human
a hundred percent is it is
humanity and look even the best person
on earth has done horrible things yeah
john legend the best person on earth
and like and that was a joke but yeah i
mean everybody's a piece of [ __ ] you
can't not it's not a piece of [ __ ] it's
just like but everybody has [ __ ] on them
of course everybody has [ __ ] on their
shoes and some people in their shoes
yeah it's it's really confusing and like
i try
one of the things i'm really working on
is like not taking things personally
yeah just trying that on
and uh it's hard because you're but it's
like when i as i'm setting this
intention i'm seeing it more clearly
that like when someone does something to
piss me off they're not even thinking
about me they're fully viewing it
through their own [ __ ] up lens or
whatever pain they're going through you
know what i mean right yeah right and
we've also gotten so in our own world
that that's the only lens we even have
anymore so you're not even looking at
things as a two-way street i noticed a
few years ago when the elevator would
open people would get in it used to
always be yeah it was always yeah people
got out first you wait it was just a
natural thing and then now people get in
yeah as it's like yeah it's all kind of
i don't know it's hard to know if it's
it's hard to know if how much of what we
are
[Music]
like suffering from or will suffer from
if
if it's like side effects of like
society or if it's just like
this
this flaw inside of us i don't know it's
all of it it's not a it's not a flaw i
would encourage you to think of it
differently
what i like you know the guy i learned a
breath or crow he divine healing as just
what i love about it is because it takes
all the pathology away and just that
healing is just like giving love to the
places that hurt
you know instead of like broken illness
like
all these like
things that we think are flaws or our
brokenness or like make us unlovable
and that is something i love about
breathwork because it's so pure it's
just something
giving your god-given
like natural structure putting it to use
and
remembering the divinity of who you are
yeah
it's a lot do you think that like
but if we didn't have like flaw if we
didn't do you think we ever get to a
place where it's all evened out or it's
just always this constant
no because
that would be
perfection and perfection doesn't exist
yeah and like trying for that is pain
like
you know when you get into it
like of course you want to be stable
and you want to be feeling good a
majority of the time but
i think the definition of mental health
is being able to feel the full spectrum
of emotions in a healthy way
yeah
yeah i would say that that's probably
sounds pretty fair to me
i would like that
yeah
but like when we like when i think then
you get into spiritual bypassing which
is like toxic positivity which isn't
like actually addressing how you feel or
whatever
um as some way of like enlightenment and
the fact is we're just all human you
know
yeah i thought being human would be
easier kind of
no
no because everyone's dealt like
whatever cards are dealt and i think
it's just like our cosmic lessons on
earth
yeah i think for some reason i felt like
it would be easier
um i feel like uh
it looks pretty good from from where i'm
sitting
oh thank you
i did wash my hair two days ago i meant
your life
oh
yeah no my life is uh yeah i think it
doesn't matter it's always like what you
are
yeah i don't know i felt like
i i always felt like if i got to a
certain level of like doing well in my
job or maybe then i would
then everything would be okay i think i
had this preconceived notion in my head
that like all these other things that i
worry about or feel or these discomforts
will disappear so when i started to have
some success and that didn't happen
uh i think i was like kind of like there
was a part of me i didn't even know this
motor was running that expected this
yeah you know then it was like oh you're
still just you know with
with your weights i think that's
completely
[Music]
natural thought like
we're all looking for something to save
us whether it's like success love
whatever it is yeah botox
orthotics um
yeah but i think like wealth and money
and success
really just brings out even more of what
is already there yeah
um i'm sure it makes a lot of other
things easier
well mark norman said it best about
having a little bit of money here's what
it makes easier if you are cold or
something and you're at like a gas
station or something you don't have to
like you know you don't have to look at
the price of the suit you're like okay i
just can get this sweatshirt you know
like little things like that are kind of
nicer like do i need like
how much is this lunch it's like it
saves you a little bit of time and
having to look at some price tags if
it's something big like a car or
something you're gonna look but like for
re you know it's like that kind of stuff
is a little bit nice you have to think
about the cost of like uh you know
really a meal maybe or something you
know yeah those things are kind of a
little bit nice to have
to have happen maybe um so take me so i
tried ketamine therapy was one thing
that i tried like in the past
seven months maybe how many times did
you do it i did six times so it was six
six sessions cool you sit with a
therapist in a room yeah and they fill
you up and then you you know are talking
with this therapist the psychiat
psychiatrist the whole time yeah so
you're kind of going through things and
like sharing and
um
i found that that was really interesting
i felt maybe for like trauma
like one specific trauma or something
did you go deep in that
i was sometimes i was off the wall i
mean i was like in another echelon
did you find it helpful
i found it helpful some i got to have
some moments like
i got to
spend time with my dad for like about 45
seconds
which was pretty cool yeah that's really
cool yeah just to let him know that i
loved him i felt like he never knew
maybe wow and it felt real like it felt
as real as this sitting here talking
yeah that's really beautiful so to have
something like that happen where it's
like um
i got to see my mom when she was a
little kid
which was pretty powerful i felt like um
you know uh
did they do like inner child work
i don't know the dude had a big beard i
know that was running it so i'm sure
he's [ __ ] definitely done some things
man this dude he had one of those crazy
[ __ ] you know no no in your child did
you work with your in your child no no
no we didn't see him
we was more just doing like regular
i feel like that's like a big direction
that people are going in with therapy
and healing is just like going back to
your inner child yeah because they say
like your entire subconscious
blueprint for the rest of the your life
is developed from zero to seven years
old wow so whatever goes down then
is really
like
your whole framework which is so crazy
because it's completely out of our
control yeah so
yeah yeah i i went to this other place
called pcs for a week and it's like um
like this guy bobby lee this comedian
recommended to me do you know who that
is
so and he's i think vietnamese or
something but he recommended it to me
and he um
uh that place is all about your inner
child like you gotta go to build a bear
and get like a little child yeah so
you're in there with like a bunch of
yeah it's really i've done [ __ ] like it
is so dicey we're in there there's like
a bunch of [ __ ] oh yeah there's like
there's like a bunch of grown men in
this build-a-bear and there's like a
bunch of kids in there there's like a
kid's party and we're [ __ ] putting
dresses and like oh yeah this one will
wear it look good in a baseball outfit
so then you're leaving the mall with
your bears like oh and you're like it's
heartbreaking yeah it is heartbreaking
wait and then somebody's like dude
you're my favorite comedian you're
[ __ ] humiliating
oh my god
you're buying a bear dude and the lady
putting the stuffing in there the one
lady her [ __ ] gum i remember fell on
the stuffing thing and she's like
it's just a nightmare in there just a
real but it was kind of like how god
does it it was like you know you got all
this cotton and you're just [ __ ]
stuffing it into these bears dude and
you're just sending them out the door
you know and sometimes there's some bad
knitting yeah no [ __ ] yeah did you did
you get a lot out of it
it was pretty fast uh some of it i did
some emdr i noticed i would be real
judgmental going into some of the
sessions like just like um
you know judgment is like something that
keeps me
it's a like a
preventative thing to keep me from
connection so i'm gonna have to have
some feelings or something so there was
stuff like that uh
it was kind of exhausting some of the
therapies it was like some group stuff i
didn't like but there was some stuff i
really did like
yeah i find like that group stuff
i mean now i've worked on it and stuff
but like at first i was like
no [ __ ] way i was like i'm not
talking about anything like in a group
or in front of people which is so weird
because
like i've been i've been doing comedy
like i speak publicly in front of crowds
all the time but like when it was about
serious [ __ ] like no
it took me a long time but that ended up
being like the most healing thing for me
uh doing group therapy it wasn't group
therapy it's 12 step
but i don't want to say that which one
right so like recovery yeah
yeah recovery i feel like is the best
overall solution that i've found
honestly do you feel that way or no
totally and it ended up being because
the
community because like you know where i
grew up uh it's just no one talks about
mental health no one talks about
anything like
never heard any no one talks about their
problems like it's very buttoned up
and that's the way my family was too and
i'm just the total opposite like i'm
very sensitive i feel a lot of things
i'm interested in a lot of things like i
want to talk about
things um and so when i got to recovery
like and i i remember when i first saw
people i knew because it's la and
there's like a lot of people and
entertainment in there of course
and i was like i was trying to hide from
them like it didn't cross my mind that
they're there too i was just like oh no
they're seeing me here right you know um
yeah i even think that went on zoom
meeting sometimes yeah i was on one
yesterday i didn't want to show my face
because i'm like totally
you don't want to be you don't want to
be like
known in this private way so i didn't
talk like the first couple of years but
then when i started talking is like when
i experienced a lot of uh progression
and how was the ayahuasca tell me about
that experience take me through that uh
it was really cool i i wanted to do it
forever i'm just like curious and um ron
white did it too oh really yeah he did
it at a damn best western
in
[Music]
outside i want to say in h near houston
yeah nobody tell my parents i did
ayahuasca they really wouldn't like that
um
but uh i
after i got vaccinated i did it i knew i
was gonna go back on the road and then i
was like what if i like
fall in love and
like get married and i probably and have
children i'm not gonna be able to like
be a mom that goes and does dmt you know
right you gotta do it now yeah i gotta
do it now so i just saw like a window
and it was really the window came
actually
uh everyone had always said like don't
do it in la it's like sketchy white
people whatever i'd always wanted to go
to the amazon but i was like go to
memphis and do it dude that's i'm sure a
real dicey dose yeah um okay go on so i
found like uh i had found like a
tangible someone had had a great
experience and so i just went i went by
myself which the day of when i was like
driving to this sketchy ass property
i was like this might be a bad idea was
it off a melrose no it was like
out an hour outside of la in a
tiny farming town and i was like driving
up to this like desolate property and i
was like this is a bad idea but i text
my friend i was like three of my friends
i was like here's the address check in
at this time and immediately like their
guardians um
the men when they said hello they hugged
you and i was like i don't like this
yeah that's i do not like the forced
over familiarity like i don't want you
to hug me two arm hug or one arm hug
oh yeah
like hello from a man were they wearing
jewelry
um
there was some jewelry for sure but it
ended up
i was like if somebody with two arms and
jewelry hugs you dude
i'm calling the cops yeah but i was like
i guess i'm in like i did the whole and
it was just you by yourself it was me by
myself no
dude how and no there was a huge group
of people but i didn't know anyone
i never met because i would feel like if
you're going through like sexual trauma
and then you roll up to three dudes at a
damn rant oh no
get the [ __ ] out i wanna sprint i'll
spread out of there um
you just rolled through this hitting a
volleyball around you like this
yeah
hey what's up we're here for round two
um
no like i
i
i'm sorry i interrupted your story no
it's okay but it ended up being really
really cool um i had you have to
prepare so much like you can't um drink
sm like i don't smoke but you can't like
me caffeine all these things like
before so there's like a whole large
preparation
um
and then uh
i listen to podcasts and documentaries
and basically they're all like like
aubry marcus and stuff and they're all
sad like
you're gonna go to the darkest [ __ ]
place you're gonna experience terror but
then on the other side you'll feel great
and so i went in there like i was just
like it's just gonna take me and i'm
gonna go and i'm just going to hold on
with eye black on yeah
get a sharp tampon
i could [ __ ] do this and that was
like the full opposite experience really
i got i was taken to like a pink
marshmallow jungle and like my message
because like you know my thing has been
learning to feel safe in my body
was like that the universe is kind which
sounds like a really
uh
anticlimactic distillation
but
and try but that's really like it went
in me yeah that's good that's a cool
that's an amazing message to have in you
have you in your [ __ ]
yeah marrow after that that's huge yeah
but they also said they'd never heard
someone cry like that really yeah and do
you cry like on all fours you cry
standing up are you leaning against
something like what is the vibe in there
um they're like you have sort of like
the you're on the ground with like these
padded chairs and they're playing um you
know
the icarus like they're playing music
the whole time and there's all these
rituals and it's very sacred is the ac
on or not
i don't
i think so i'm not sure i don't remember
but it was
it was really crazy i i've done much the
drug i like is mushrooms that's really
the only drug i do
um
and
i'd never seen visuals before like this
i didn't know
your brain could even see those things
yeah yeah
it sounds like dm like something like
dmt or something like that it is dmt
though oh it is okay but from the amazon
but
you know for breath work you can have a
psychedelic experience because we have a
certain amount of dmt in our spinal
fluid
everyone does so you can
through the alkalization of your blood
sometimes
like how i've had full visuals during
breath work before wow really
yeah
i haven't had or like weird memories pop
in where you're like i haven't thought
about that in 20 years or yeah or just
like a
solution just like pops into like
something and you're like why didn't i
think about that before yeah yeah
yeah it is such a relief when you can
kind of do something different with your
brain
i feel like some of my brain gets tired
of just being on the road you know it's
like your brain
is really exhausting and really hard on
your body and
spirit especially if you're a really
sensitive person to your environment
yeah
i would believe that
you ain't ever done ayahuasca i met a
guy at a smoothie shop
and uh
maui that gave me some uh he was a
shaman mm-hmm
or he had i mean he had sandals on and
he was out you know he was out he was he
definitely had a buddy with like he had
a buddy who literally he was like
standing with armfuls of vitamins
and uh
and they gave me a bunch of vitamins and
then the guy
took me to like a
they were doing like child care like
even at their house and i'm in there
just like relax and have me relax out in
next thing you know i'm out on the dmt
oh you did dmt yeah and it was really
that really blew my mind i can't even
believe that that has ever even existed
in the universe and then that can happen
wow i don't even know what
um taking dmt would probably be very
similar to the ayahuasca experience i
bet it's really hardcore but what the
purpose of it is is the tough thing i
don't really know exactly i would like
that made me realize
you know i've done mushrooms and stuff
but i was like
this was like a really sacred thing and
i was like i don't need to in my
lifetime be [ __ ] around with
like drugs
outside of like this very controlled
sacred environment for me i don't have
any judgment to other people but how
long were you at the ayahuasca place i
was there for a weekend and you take um
three cups
a night but most people don't get to the
third cup and each cup is a level 1
through 10
but
it's completely arbitrary like a 1 could
hit someone at a 10 and a 10 could just
be like not a big deal for someone
so it's like
yeah you really have to be open to
whatever experience because you never
you have no idea what's going to happen
and do you like defecate yourself or
people wearing diapers and stuff because
i always heard a lot about like yeah you
like purge are people vomiting and
urinating and stuff um i did not ship my
pants thank you jesus um
but i did throw up both nights it wasn't
a big deal like it was really fast and
then they the guardians come clear the
bucket really fast
um i think some people do go to the
bathroom i don't think people [ __ ]
themselves this the second night i was
like out of my body it was like it was
so intense and are you are there other
people around is it like yeah they're
all around you you're in a vietnam kind
of yeah they're like
people were on both sides of me like
this and they have all the women on one
side and all the men on
one side like are people tickling each
other and [ __ ] or haven't bothered to
touch anyone
they like enforce everything so hard so
that everyone's like safe and are there
referees i got like roller everybody i'm
getting like this vibe of like a roller
skating rink where the guys like you
know there's some guy like i know
it's not like that at all like they take
it so seriously and there's people
taking care of anyone that needs to be
taken care of um
but yeah it's a whole experience you
have to prepare so much it takes a lot
out of you
like spiritually and physically and yeah
yeah
hmm
um
how's comedy going do you feel good
about it how long have you been doing it
now
it's good
um
i just didn't know what else to ask i've
been doing it like a little over eight
years oh that's awesome um it's good
like i'm you know booking stuff and uh
starting to feel like
i
am on my way to success
uh
i just did a movie i'm on a new comedy
central show
um
things are going well
yeah that's exciting it is because i
don't want to be [ __ ] broke i want to
be rich yeah yeah
yeah i mean people want to be rich man i
mean but what a
better joy
i mean because i've been so
experienced being broke for so long and
like what a joy
to have found a way
to make money doing what you love yeah
yeah i mean it's such
it's such a gift like i don't take it
for granted at all like any paycheck i
get it's just like a miracle because i'm
having so much fun and
i could have just quit on myself so
early on in some marketing job not that
there's anything wrong with a marketing
job it just wasn't right for my wild
soul right yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't
mind doing a little bit of marketing i
got a degree in uh
urban planning
really yeah whoa what you [ __ ] plan
we do like neighborhoods and
like if say if like a mailman's coming
like you know then we design like what
route to take through the neighborhood
we do a lot of like sims
yeah kind of like sims actually that's
pretty good yeah it's like sims yeah
theo sims yeah
maybe that'll be maybe i'll start a theo
sims game
um
but yeah i was doing her we do urban
planning where to put the power lines
where to put the bike path we do all
that how's some comedy going for you we
do all that it's going pretty good i
think you know i'm doing a new tour
right now so i'm pretty excited about
that with ari um yup ari mantis is out
there sometimes most of the time
actually or he's a new friend of mine oh
he is yeah oh yeah he's good he'll
definitely be in
he'll be in recovery at some point but
uh until then man you know
he just sometimes hears me on these zoom
meetings he's a wild dude oh yeah he's
one of a kind i mean he is definitely
something else i did his podcast oh you
did oh i hear now i see
are you getting these guests first
that's cool no he's a sweetheart
um i'm lucky to have uh you know i feel
like when i'm around him he makes things
he's so red i mean there's just the guys
there's so many things about him yeah
he's so wild dude yeah he's definitely a
real snake owner
you know
he's definitely and that's not a
euphemism the guy owns snakes oh wow so
i didn't know that about him
yeah ari if you see this that's [ __ ]
nasty yeah
yeah yeah
he knows it is i think that's why he
does it all right i'm praying for you
ari you need it yeah yeah yeah
he does need it um
blair sake i appreciate thanks for
coming and chatting with me and hanging
out yeah for sure it's really fun um to
talk to you outside of brother i know
it's crazy because we only talk to each
other on zoom yeah yeah
um yeah it's so crazy once you like
that's how you talk to someone on zoom
and yeah because i don't really know you
but i know one like specific little like
intimate part
right that i like to breathe deep
yeah
here's what's here's what's so fast if
you don't if you've never done this
the the lesson you give i mean i have to
inhale and exhale for about 25 minutes
like about 30 and it's really it's
rigorous it's really really hard i
always telling colin that i
experience more resistance to doing it
than working out yeah like i would
rather work out than do it because it's
so
hard to get to make yourself
do that consistent rhythm for 30 minutes
yeah it's really hard
yeah i'm trying to think so this is how
i was doing it just because i was like
uh
yeah do i need to speed it up or does it
matter
no you're supposed to go at your own
pace the way that i teach the class i've
told you this but i started it starts
out slow and gets faster okay yeah and
then you know you do hear say five
percent more let's get five percent more
guys then i'm like on a [ __ ] peloton
side yeah yeah yeah what's going on yeah
um that doesn't mean faster or harder
but it's more into your stomach
um
and then like you experience the
shavasana porous portion where you just
rest and like feel it all the work you
just did like coursing through your body
it's so cool oh yeah i feel it up in
here yeah i feel that [ __ ] ripping
yeah or like if you have physical
ailments like
it can be really cool for that oh it
feels like [ __ ] a bunch of heavy
monkeys are pulling on my veins yeah
[ __ ] feels intense yeah it's wild
um
awesome well if you want to check it out
with blair we'll put a link in do you do
you do that for people or are you kind
of just in a safe world doing it for
convenience that you want um well i'll
randomly do like a virtual class which i
am doing on this coming tuesday but i
don't know if it'll be out by then but
okay cool but if not they can follow you
and they can figure out where to uh take
your classes sometime yeah if i do do
one i'll post about it okay good yeah
cool blair sake best of luck with comedy
and stuff is so nice to meet you yeah
thank you thanks for having me this was
really
[Music]
oh fun when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
in my bones
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let
[Music]
sit and myself you my stories